[Music]
so here's one way to dramatically
improve your time in college sports just
change your gender a man at the
university of pennsylvania now says he's
a woman and as a result he's completely
dominating the competition
he goes by lyla thomas and recently won
a race a swimming race by more than 38
seconds if you don't think about
swimming 38 seconds is like the normal
equivalent of like four days
because that's just like there are no 38
second differences between top
competitors in a swim meet but thomas
says he should be allowed to compete in
any category because he doesn't have an
unfair advantage
i think
the guidelines they step forward are
very good and
do
a very good job of
promoting inclusivity while keeping
um
competitional integrity um
going
everybody is
able to compete
um
in the category they're most comfortable
with
unless there's
a
proven
unfair advantage that they have
not attacking the kid obviously but what
about everybody else everyone else who
has to pretend that that's true it's
like pretending that omicron which
doesn't actually kill people is somehow
a terrifying threat to our civilization
it's like a lie it's insane and if you
have to go along with it you're degraded
because you're complicit in the
dishonesty
one person who's brave enough to point
this out was the editor-in-chief of
swimming world magazine who compared
thomas's advantage to doping and that
seemed like a big change like an adult
in the room clay travis has always been
an adult in the room he's the founder of
outkick he joins us clay thanks so much
for coming on so the editor of a
swimming magazine pointing out what's
clear to every rational person seems
like
an advance to me
look tucker you're exactly right about
this first thanks for having me on
second this is absolute insanity all
right right you have got a biological
man who didn't just uh decide to become
a female swimmer he was good enough to
be on the university of pennsylvania
men's team and then he sits out for a
year decides to identify as a woman and
shows up and dominates all of women's
swimming we're talking about this guy
potentially breaking every college
women's swimming record that has ever
existed every woman out there who has
ever competed as a swimmer or really
competed in women's athletics at all who
gets up early in the morning who puts in
every ounce of their ability into their
pursuit of swimming every feminist every
title ix advocate should be standing up
and screaming for the heavens from the
heavens this is unacceptable because men
are bigger stronger and faster
biologically than women this is totally
absurd but what you get tucker and you
know this is when two left-wing
ideologies identity politics collide you
got feminist and title ix supporters on
one side who support women's athletics
and then you've got the trans agenda on
the other side you have to pick a side
and what often happens in these stories
look at people who cover sports media
they just pretend it doesn't exist espn
you know this they love to cover every
single conflict of sports and politics
they haven't written a single story
about this tucker it's a sham not one
every time somebody doesn't go to the
white house to visit trump it's the lead
story on espn for five years a
biological man threatens to become the
greatest women swimmer of all time and
they don't even cover it they pretend it
doesn't exist well maybe that's what
they're i mean espn used to be so
impressive it was famous in the tv
business for having the smartest
producers impressive people went to espn
and then their numbers tanked because
they became liars like they're just
liars so who would watch that
well not only that tucker it's the very
foundation and essence of sports that's
why we watch to see the best man or the
best woman win right we have look and by
the way we don't even have to talk about
the transgender agenda you've got kids
i've got kids we don't let 10 year olds
compete against 18 year olds in little
league baseball right we don't let the
flyweight boxers who weigh 120 pounds go
fight heavyweight boxers like mike tyson
back in the day because we know that's
not a fair fight we have all sorts of
regulations right big high schools don't
play little high schools and yet we've
got somehow a man deciding to become a
woman and he's going to be the greatest
women swimmer of all time i mean i got a
good email about this recently you'll
appreciate it what if lebron james at
the end of his nba career decided he
didn't want to quit playing basketball
and wanted to become a wnba star and be
the best men's and women's basketball
player of all time because he's not
going to catch jordan are we going to
allow that he could be the best women's
basketball player until he's 65 probably
it's a farce it's ludicrous it's insane
but this is where far left-wing politics
mixed with sports elitist tucker it's
it's it's an absolute unmitigated
disaster
i kind of hope lebron james does go to
the wnba because really
no two have ever deserved one another
more you know what i'm absolutely
rooting for that uh actually come to
think of it what if tucker that was his
play to catch jordan in championships
he's not gonna catch him otherwise but
what if he starts to argue hey i got
four men's championships and then i
added on three women's championships in
the wnba i did catch jordan in
championships i dare you to call him on
it it's absurd but i would love this
maybe espn wouldn't even cover that
story we're encouraging it strongly i'd
love to see the politicized ladies of
the w i love this answer explain why
that can't happen clay travis great to
see you merry christmas thanks a lot